- MEN, AS WE LAUNCH
THE COUNTERATTACK
AGAINST THE UNION ARMY,
WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE MAY DIE
A GLORIOUS DEATH
ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
WE DO SO TO PRESERVE
A WAY OF LIFE.
THE SOUTHERN WAY OF LIFE.
A WAY OF LIFE
SO PURE AND BEAUTIFUL
THAT NO MAN NOR GOVERNMENT
CAN TAKE THIS AWAY FROM US.
THE RIGHT...
THE RIGHT TO PRESERVE.
OUR OWN SO--
TO--
WE A--
OH, [bleep].
- WELL, HELLO THERE, MASSA.
SORRY WE LATE.
- SHORE DIDN'T MEAN
TO SNEAK UP ON YA, SIR.
- LOOK, FELLAS,
WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE
A NICE, LITTLE CIVIL WAR
REENACTMENT HERE.
WE DON'T WANT ANY TROUBLE.
- SO ARE WE, SIR.
WE--WE--WE TRYING TO HAVE
A REAL NICE REENACTMENT.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANNA CAUSE
ANY TROUBLE EITHER.
DO WE, SAM?
- YOU ALWAYS TAUGHT US
TROUBLE ONLY COMES TO THOSE
WHO GONE DONE LOOKIN' FOR IT.
- SO DON'T STOP YOUR SPEECHIN'
ON OUR ACCOUNT.
[giggles]
- AS JEFFERSON DA--OKAY, I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. I GET IT.
- WHAT WE DOIN', SIR?
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU TALKIN' 'BOUT.
DO YOU KNOW
WHAT HE TALKIN' 'BOUT, SAM?
- WHY, WE JUST HERE
TO SLAVE ON ABOUT,
ANY OLE WHICH WAY
YOU WANT US TO.
- HOW MANY TIMES
DO I HAVE TO TELL PEOPLE,
JUST BECAUSE WE'RE DRESSED
LIKE CONFEDERATE SOLDIERS
DOESN'T MEAN
WE'RE PRO SLAVERY?
WE'RE JUST HERE TO PRESERVE
THE PURE AND BEAUTIFUL SLICE
OF SOUTHERN HISTORY.
- YEAH, PURE AND BEAUTIFUL...
SLICE.
- OH, LORDY, LORDY, LORDY!
WE SORRY, BOSS!
OH, WE SO SORRY!
- PLEASE DON'T
GIVE US THE WHIP.
- OKAY, NOBODY'S GONNA WHIP
ANYBODY, JUST STOP IT.
- YEAH, JUST STOP IT.
- ALL RIGHT, FELLAS, JUST--
JUST IGNORE 'EM.
ALL RIGHT?
NOW, WE'RE HERE
TO PRESERVE OUR WAY OF LIFE.
THE SOUTH HAS A RIGHT TO OWN--
both: ♪ OH, MY LORD, LORD ♪
- THE SOUTH
HAS A WAY OF LIFE--
both: ♪ OH, MY LORD ♪
- THE UNION CANNOT STOP US FR--
both: ♪ OH, MY LORD, LORD ♪
♪ OH, MY LORD... ♪
- THE UNION YANKEE BASTARDS
CANNOT STOP US--
- ♪ OH, LORD! ♪
- ALL RIGHT, STOP IT!
STOP IT! THAT'S ENOUGH!
YOU WANNA BE PART OF THIS
REENACTMENT?
FINE.
YOU'RE PART OF IT.
GO--GO FETCH US SOME MUNITIONS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT--
DON'T JUST STAND THERE
LIKE A BUNCH OF LAZY [bleep].
- THAT GOOD ENOUGH FOR YOU?
- THAT IS ALL I NEEDED TO HEAR.
- GENTLEMEN,
GIVE US YOUR CASH
AND ANYTHING THAT IS
AN ACTUAL COLLECTOR'S ITEM.
- YOU RACIST MOTHER[bleep].
- OKAY.
DON'T HAVE ALL DAY, MAN.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WALLETS, WALLETS,
WALLETS, WALLETS.
- THAT'S A VERY NICE PIECE.
THESE ARE HEAVY.